2022 has been a really fascinating year
for movies I'm pretty hopeful about
Cinema in general I think there's a lot
of quality stuff being made out there
it's just having to compete with this
endless void of near infinite content
that's coming at us from all directions
right now my top 10 list is very Loosely
ranked what makes it onto the list
usually gets there because of one or
more of three things how well the movie
resonated with me emotionally which is
very personally subjective obviously my
interest level in the ideas themes and
Concepts that it's exploring and then
third how well the movie is kind of
wielding filmmaking as a form and or
pushing the boundaries of that Medium to
do something that feels new original and
fresh to me actually trying to establish
what the best movies from a year were is
a total Fool's errand especially before
the year is even over there are still a
bunch of movies that potentially would
have made it onto this list that I
haven't had the time to see or just
aren't even available for me to watch
but what these lists are good for is
starting a discussion so let's hang out
talk about movies and share with me your
top 10 from this year in the comments
below final note I will keep this list
spoiler free so you can watch this
without worrying about whether or not
you've seen any of the movies on this
list
this video is sponsored by mubi get your
extended 30-day free trial at movie.com
thomasflight
first let's get to some honorable
mentions so there are two movies that I
got to see at can earlier this year
Lucas dontz close and also Kelly
reichart showing up but I'm bumping them
to the running for next year because
they're getting a wide release in the
U.S in 2023 but they would almost
certainly be in my top 10 for this year
other honorable mentions are after Yang
from video essayist turned director
kagananda after Yang is a soft kind of
gentle science fiction film that I think
really shows what can be done with the
genre at that smaller scale in a genre
where a lot of stuff is huge big high
concept often dark or sort of dystopian
it's cool to watch something that just
puts forward a more simple beautiful
science fiction world I also want to
mention the worst person in the world
from Jacob and Trier that released way
back in February which is a genuinely
funny and emotional indictment of kind
of millennial malaise that I think still
manages to be compassionate and
insightful all while doing so with kind
of stylistic flair I also want to
mention White Noise the Noah bombach
adaptation of the Don delillo novel I
love the novel and I don't know if this
movie quite manages to elevate the novel
but it was fun to see a really faithful
adaptation in theaters and it's a it's a
fun movie finally I want to mention
Memoria by a picture this is a movie
that came out last year but which is
still slowly touring theaters City by
city I really loved this kind of bizarre
meditative Art House sci-fi and I can't
wait to watch it again once it's out on
video but in the meantime I definitely
recommend keeping an eye out and if it
comes to your city check it out now
let's jump into my Loosely ranked top 10
of 2022.
different people are going to want
different things from the movies and one
of the things I've always really valued
for whatever reason is commitment
commitment to the vision commitment to a
concept A Story a perspective nine out
of ten times I'd rather watch a movie
shoot for something really interesting
and specific and Miss slightly rather
than watch somebody absolutely nail what
is a tried and true formula the main
appeal of Robert Eggers films for me is
this his 100 absolute commitment to the
bid and for me the Northman completely
exemplifies this in a year of really
unique movies there's truly no other
movie like the Norsemen that came out
this year there's an intention to lore
and detail here that I really appreciate
but I think most interestingly to me it
feels like the movie really commits to
the perspective of the myth it's telling
the Northman doesn't feel like a movie
about a myth it feels like a myth itself
like what Vikings might make if they got
their hands on cameras
next up on the list is decision to leave
a razor-sharp neo-noir from South Korean
director Park Chan wuk it's built around
a convoluted Twisted mystery that Rivals
the best noirs out there this is one of
those like Double Indemnity kind of
plots about two people who are
absolutely perfectly terrible for each
other and just watching them Collide in
a disastrous mess that you can't look
away from and you won't want to look
away because Park is flying you through
the very heart of this relationship with
the camera at Breakneck speed he's
putting cameras in eyeballs and phones
and flying the camera around through
time and moving characters in space I've
never seen someone intercut the
beginning of one scene with the end of
another in the way he does in this movie
like one out of every three shots in
this movie is absolutely stunning it
kind of astounds me that he was able to
pack so much interesting
fresh original Direction into one film
and it's a great compelling story but
it's also worth checking out just for
studying what he's doing in this film
I looked here
whatever it is you're fighting about
next up is the Banshees of inner Sharon
this movie brings back the Gleason feral
Duo that I loved from one of Martin
mcdonough's earlier films in Bruges and
it's a very different relationship here
but the duo is no less compelling it's a
movie about conflict between two friends
but that conflict is really emblematic
of other larger conflicts in a way that
is really interesting and works really
well there's an examination of the value
of art versus the value of kind of
friendship and respect for other people
the conflict is also emblematic of
larger conflict in Ireland and loss of
meaning within this specific community
and to that end I think this movie has
maybe the strongest sense of place out
of any movie that I watched this year so
it's kind of a cliche to say like the
location is a character but it's really
true here not just in how the location
is shot with the cinematography which I
think is some of the best photography
I've ever seen of Irish landscape in a
movie but also just in how the pace of
Island life kind of seeps into even the
delivery of the dialogue and the editing
of the film you really feel like you're
inside this place and that allows you to
understand the impact that being there
has on all the characters and all the
characters are amazing some of the best
performances from a Supporting Cast this
year I think are in this movie this
movie immerses you in a world by the end
you're going to be haunted by the same
banshees as everyone else on the island
people who watch my channel know that
like it's a bigger Blockbuster stuff
isn't necessarily my usual Vibe but I
think this was actually kind of an
amazing year for larger Blockbuster
films I think Ryan cooglers wakanda
forever was one of the most interesting
MCU films that I've seen in a long time
I think he was pushing what you can do
with an MCU film in an interesting
Direction the Batman is by far the best
superhero movie I've seen in a long time
in terms of production I made a video
about its sound design earlier this year
we also had top gun Maverick which kind
of came out of nowhere so I wanted to
ask my podcast co-host Tom Vanderlinden
why he thought that movie deserves to be
among the best of the Year top gun
Maverick was one of the biggest movies
this year in terms of theatrical
audience response and it's movie I
enjoyed but I think struggled to connect
with in the same way that I feel like a
lot of people who really enjoyed it did
and I know it's a movie that you really
liked Tom so I'm just curious your
thoughts on why you think Top Gun
deserves to be considered one of the
best movies of this year I think that
for me I I have Nostalgia to watch the
original I kind of went into this one
blind and
I expected it to be this great action
movie you know Tom Cruise has been well
known by now for doing all this stuff
for real and practically and you know
the way this real fighter jets and was
going to be really cool
and indeed it was but what surprised me
was that it was actually very emotional
in the sense that there was this
underlying sense of
I'd call it heroic optimism in the way
that the whole story felt like it had
this energy wherein people could come
together they could work together
Elevate each other by you know pushing
each other to the limits and then go
beyond them and achieve this common goal
or common purpose and I felt like that
was just something so
universally beautiful about that you
know even though that's the relation
with the military and War which we've
discussed but which you know I had a
little bit of an easier time to
disconnect from seeing as I'm not from a
very militaristic country but yeah for
me it just that energy is for me what
kind of resonated
the strongest with me and what made this
movie so
moving beyond its
initial experience or its superficial
experience almost as a pure action film
I really thought Top Gun might be
unabashedly the most sincere movie that
we were gonna get this year but it might
be rivaled by my pick for favorite kind
of big Blockbuster of the year which to
my utter surprise I'm finding is Avatar
2. I really did not expect this movie to
be on this list and it was a last minute
Edition and despite kind of liking the
original I had pretty lukewarm
expectations going into this one and I
wasn't sure at first there's a lot of
rough edges here this is far from a
perfect movie but over the course of
this movies three hour and 12 minute run
time or whatever ridiculous length it is
it kind of to be honest won me over this
movie's VFX are something that stand
completely on their own watching them
this is really more like playing
Half-Life Alex in VR than it is like
watching a movie which is not to say
better but just a completely unique and
kind of original experience on its own
that comparison is probably either going
to be a huge selling point or downside
depending on your persuasion as a viewer
a lot of that just comes down to how
much you enjoy the visceral experience
of watching this movie but I honestly
don't think the visuals and beauty of
the experience are just an empty candy
coating they're a critical part of the
story James Cameron is trying to get you
to fall in love with this world and then
he's putting that world under direct
attack for dramatic effect and with
these movies he's doing something really
interesting which is modeling sort of an
attitude of Engagement with the world in
these movies it's aliens engaging with a
fake world but he's modeling a certain
type of curiosity and attention and care
here that can be given to the world that
is really an important one to not lose
sight of for ourselves in our own real
world I think we should be getting lost
in sort of the Wonder and excitement and
joy of our own natural world and so to
have a big Blockbuster movie kind of
exemplifying that for like an hour in
the middle is sort of a special thing I
don't know of other movies that come
anywhere close to doing that kind of
thing besides maybe like the tree of
life or the latest nature documentary
from Disney plus the way of water never
quite escapes the high camp of James
Cameron but if I'm going to talk about
commitment in movies this movie is
committed to whatever it is that James
Cameron is doing it's 100 committed and
unexpectedly I found myself on board
our society is gripped by spectacle
right now spectacle that is transmitted
via images and the best most nuanced
exploration of that this year was
probably Jordan peele's nope I love that
Jordan peel is doing this kind of thing
in his latest sort of horror Adventure
spin nope was the movie I had the most
fun picking apart this year and despite
multiple viewings I still have the
feeling that there's more left there to
be discovered in the future the movie
has an incredible sense of rhyme there's
seemingly disconnected elements that are
connected through sound design or
imagery or thematic resonance that might
feel disparate at first but as you
examine this thing and re-watch it it
really all kind of comes together into
this cohesive whole I think peels past
movies have been great but I'm also
excited to see him stepping into a kind
of thematic exploration that's a little
bit more poetic it has great sound
performances writing it's the first
horror movie shot on IMAX it pioneered a
completely new form of day for night
cinematography there's way more I could
say here but I'd just be repeating what
I've already said in the two videos I
made about nope so you can go check
those out if you're interested
why do the greatest directors that have
lived do what they do make the art they
make this is a question that I find
fascinating it's obviously one that I've
spent a lot of time exploring on this
channel and it's a question I love
because behind any piece of art or
entertainment that captures the
imagination and attention of a bunch of
viewers is a person or group of people
who made that thing for a reason and
those reasons don't Define the art
itself but it's very interesting still
to examine those reasons not only to
better understand the art but so we can
better understand ourselves why we
connect with certain things and why we
make the things we do so it's kind of
fascinating anytime a director turns the
lens more Inward and
examines their own personal journey and
that can be fraught it doesn't always
turn out well sometimes it's a more
egoic Endeavor than anything but when
Steven Spielberg does it it's a delight
because he does it in only the sort of
personal
completely heartfelt and captivating way
that Steven Spielberg could Sammy
fableman is using the camera to kind of
cope and process painful situations in
his life and in a very explicit way we
can also see Spielberg kind of doing
that with this film The Strange
Bittersweet thing about telling your own
story like this is that it can feel like
this cohesive
thing to the audience but to the artist
these things don't go away when the
credits roll it's their real life and
putting your life into a film to try to
contain that or frame it in a certain
way doesn't change the sort of reality
of those memories or that situation I
think the beauty of the Fable men's is
that it doesn't sidestep Spielberg's
place as this great filmmaker in
American history but it's still a
surprisingly humble and personal
examination of the beauty and
limitations of the artistic process
I command you enjoy the moment
now
please
no the next best movie of the year is Mr
morale and the big steppers by Kendra uh
one of the most interesting songs of the
year to me was Kendrick Lamar's we cried
together it's a song that takes the form
of a vicious fight between a couple and
there's a lot that could be said about
it but what I want to highlight here is
for me how the song captured a feeling
and that feeling is just kind of what it
feels like to be listening to society
right now this might sound completely
bizarre but triangle of sadness does
that same maneuver in comedy form can
you just stand here
okay to me what's great about triangle
of sadness is not that it has this
profound specific message or incredibly
original satire or commentary mostly
what I enjoyed about it was the way that
it just managed to capture the feeling
of being in society right now it Taps
into a vibe in a comedic way and that
Vibe is the absurdity of being in this
Society where things are kind of out of
control and a storm is battering the
ship and the upper class and the lower
class alike are all just kind of having
to go about their business and pretend
like everything's fine while the captain
of the ship is drunk and arguing about
economic theory with a Russian
capitalist
I love impressionist art there's few
things as beautiful to me as these
paintings where you can see the craft
itself the impression of each brush
stroke and if you really zoom in you'll
get lost in a world of abstraction and
won't be able to make out any of the
details but as you pull back slowly the
image itself kind of snaps into view I
can think of no better way to really
describe after sun a stunning debut from
director Charlotte Wells the movie
doesn't announce to you what it's doing
instead you just sit there with a series
of small light brush Strokes a look here
a moment of dialogue there you can tell
what's going on literally with the
characters but the why behind what's
happening is faint and obscured at first
all you can see are these individual
shapes but as you slip deeper into the
film it feels not like the movie is
telling you its story but as if it is
emerging from those Strokes as a
complete image you have a sense watching
it of discovering the story and then you
realize that all those shapes all those
individual Strokes are memories an
affect that places you in the
perspective of an adult character
actually looking back on and remembering
these events and for them the story is
also emerging out of a collection of
abstract Strokes it's only from their
perspective as an adult now that the
story is snapping into place it's a
beautiful shattering film that is gentle
heartfelt nuance and it displays how
emotion can be complex and Confused more
clearly than I think
any other film I've seen recently has
tar was the film I was probably least
expecting to see this year I knew
nothing about it going in I just knew
this is a movie
Cate Blanchette plays a composer what
unfolded surprised me by being one of
the most dense fascinating character
pieces that I've seen in the theaters in
years at the start of the film you're
thrown into the deep end of the world of
pretentious ostentatious classical
composers and the scenes that follow
carefully sketch out a character that is
haunted by their own misuse of power
we've seen this kind of character in
movies endlessly time and time again
it's one of film's most time-honored
tradition to examine the minutia of
terrible powerful people but director
Todd Fields is flipping things on their
head just enough that allows us a fresh
glimpse into this Dynamic and how it can
play out not just across gender but
across all kinds of institutions of
power or places where we venerate a
person or artist Above the value of what
they're doing in and of itself Lydia
Tara would have you think that it's only
about the art but what haunts her is
that really for her it's about anything
but that I think this movie is getting
misrepresented a little bit as being a
movie about cancel culture and it
touches on that as a theme but I think
it goes much much deeper above all it's
a rich expertly crafted character study
centered around maybe the year's best
perform elements from Key planchette
this is a movie that I know has more to
offer than what I absorbed the first
time through and I can't wait to explore
it further
back in April before everything
everywhere all at once hit theaters a24
and the writers and directors of the
movie The Daniels released a letter
explaining some of the motivation behind
why they made the movie in it they talk
about the weird feeling and pressure of
asking an audience for two hours of
their time in a world where it kind of
feels like there's already objectively
too much stuff to ever be consumed I
think it's a valid question it's when I
think about a lot why should you add to
the noise when it feels like what people
really need is less of it in the letter
they say this we realized if we were
going to make a film and ask an audience
to give us that precious time the only
responsible thing to do in return was to
blow their minds and change their lives
forever or at the very least we were
going to attempt that
at the time I read the letter I was like
okay guys chill what I didn't expect was
a movie that would actually maybe come
close to doing that I don't know if I
would say everything everywhere
changed my life but it did manage to tap
into the nerve of something and portray
certain ideas that I would say are
currently kind of changing my life this
is the only film that has come anywhere
close to capturing the sheer chaos of
what life has sometimes felt like over
the past few years a feeling I
personally linked to spending too much
time on the internet and social media in
a video that I made about the movie
earlier this Summer that you can check
out but this movie also captured a
crucial piece of something that was very
important to me this year there's a
moment amid all the Absurd chaos of this
movie that I think is very powerful and
it's powerful only because of how
chaotic and completely over the top and
ridiculous the rest of the movie is I
think it's very significant that before
there's any real change for the
characters in this film there's this
moment where they completely step back
into utter your Stillness and quiet
and examine the value of the mystery of
existence at its very core
the biggest lesson I learned in my life
this year and one that has significantly
impacted my mental health for the better
is that the answer to the overwhelming
chaos can't be found within the noise
but only by removing yourself from it
into Stillness it's why this sudden cut
to just two rocks sitting in the desert
had the most emotional impact on me out
of anything I saw in a movie this year
it's only by taking time away from the
chaos that you can really recenter
yourself and humbly return with an
understanding of what truly matters
it's the holidays and I tend to think of
this as movie season not just because a
bunch of great stuff tends to drop at
the end of the year but also because
when you get together with friends or
family it's a great time to watch some
movies that makes it the perfect time to
check out my sponsor for this video
movie mubi is an online hand curated
streaming Cinema with amazing movies
from all around the world one of the
movies I highlighted in this list
decision to leave by Park Chan Luke is
available exclusively on mubi and you
can check that out when you sign up for
an extended 30-day free trial by going
to movie.com
thomasflight mubi also makes a great
gift for people who love Cinema go to
movie.com gifts and you can choose from
between three months to a year to give
Christmas is just a few days away this
is a great last minute gift for the
other Cinema lovers in your life Cinema
is best when you can share it with other
people go to movie.com Thomas light
click the link in the description below
or on the screen to sign up for your
extended 30-day free trial thanks again
to mubi for sponsoring this video and
for another great year
[Music]